يستمر تدفقه الاف المصلين الفلسطينيين الى
المسجد الاقصى لاداء صلاه الجمعه الرابعه
من شهر رمضان المبارك وبدات بالفعل عشرات
الحافلات منذ الفجر بنقل المصلين من شمال
وجنوب ووسط الضفه الغربيه وقد شددت قوه
الاحتلال من اجراءاتها العسكريه على كافه
الحواجز مع الضفه الغربيه ونشرت منذ ساعه
الصباح الاولى ما يقارب الفي شطر شرطي في
محيطي ووسط القدس كما منعت الرجال دون سن
الخامسه والخمسين من دخول القدس والسماح
لمن هم اكبر سنا من ذلك وللنساء بالدخول
معنى الان من حاجز قلنديا في شمال القدس
مراسله الجزيره جيفارا البديري نرحب بك
جيفارا حجز قلنديا عاده ما يمتلئ كل جمعه
في الايام العاديه فما بالك في الجمعه
الاخيره من رمضان المبارك
بالفعل الازدهار هنا يتدفق الالاف
منذ ساعات الفجر الاولى ولكن كما نرى قوات
الاحتلال تتواجد تعزز ايضا من تواجدها على
العسكري على كافه
المحاور ولكن بين كل حاجز وحاجز في نفس
الحاجز هناك حاجز عسكري ان استطعنا الدخول
اكثر لنقترب من الصوره سنستطيع ان نرى عدد
كبير من جنود الاحتلال داخل الحاجز
العسكري بالطبع السلطات الاحتلال اخبرت
الفلسطينيين بان من هم فوق الخامسه
والخمسين يمكنهم الدخول وعبور واجتياز
الحواجز العسكريه وبين الخامسه والاربعين
عاما و55 عاما وان يحملون تصريح عمل
يستطيعون الدخول ولكن ما رايناه ان المئات
ان لم يكن الالاف من الفلسطينيين حصلوا
على كلمه واحده ممنوع امني دون اي تبرير
هذا ما اخبره جنود الاحتلال على الحاجز
العسكري هذا مصطلح يستخدمه الاحتلال دون
اعطاء اي تبرير حتى كبار السن يعني راينا
رجال يتجاوز عمرهم السبعين عاما ومع ذلك
حصلوا على هذه الحجه الاسرائيليه المنع
الامني ولكن مع ذلك لا زال الالاف من
الفلسطينيين يصرون على الوصول الى القدس
لاداء الجمعه الاخيره من الشهر الفضيل لا
ننسى ايضا انه في ذات الوقت هناك ايضا
الاحتفالات
الجمعه العظيمه لدى
المسيحيين وكانت ايضا الخارجيه الاردنيه
فتحذ
رت ما في المسجد الاقصى المبارك بان كل
التصديقات والقيود على الفلسطينيين لن
يسمح بها اتبع هنا نرى عدد من الرجال هم
يعني الكثير منهم فوق الخامسه والخمسين
عاما لا زالوا يحاولون الدخول عبر الهواتف
للوصول الى صفحات التي يسمح لها يسمح لهم
عبرها بالدخول الى
اماكن الحصول على التصاريح فقط يوجد
يصبح بالدخول الى اسرائيل اي الوصول الى
القدس المحتله ولكن في الا صلاه الجمعه
الا يوم الجمعه وهذا يدلل على ان
التصريحات الاسرائيليه بتسهيل دخول
الفلسطينيين الى القدس المحتله لاداء صلاه
الجمعه
المئات من الفلسطينيين هنا غير صحيحه ومع
ذلك يعني كما ذكرت لك المشهد هنا يتكرر
عند كل الحواجز والمعابر العسكريه التي
تطوق القدس المحتله بعض المصادر الغير
رسميه ومؤسسات دوليه قالت انه على الاقل
اكثر من 80 الف فلسطيني من الضفه الغربيه
صبح لهم بالدخول خاصه ان السلطات الاحتلال
سمحت في هذه الجمعه لكافه النساء بالدخول
دون تحديد اعمار
لك مراسله الجزيره من حجز قلنديا جيفارا
البديري